the important thing is now that old
white woman Nancy Pelosi is going down
at least on the bench what do they have
what's the most important thing is it
qualifications is it competency is it
your ability to do good work and that
you have the right ideas in your head
and you're going to put four things that
are going to free people or is it just
skin color
the recent people dislike on the on the
right Nancy Pelosi is because she
outlasted them she's offense because she
was effective and take a look at the
people that look like they're going to
be the next caucus leaders for the
Democrats can we pull them up
guess what you see there you see
diversity you see youth you see a woman
you see I mean it just you know it's a
it's a wonderful thing to see and it's
something that we can't ever take for
granted because just a little over 100
years ago women couldn't vote yeah and
now this woman showed us that she could
lead you see diversity you see youth
first of knowing they're looked that
young the woman in the middle is they're
leading young uh you see a woman all
right congratulations we just had a
woman again it does not nobody cares
what everyone wants right now are just
competent leaders I get it that she's a
progressive and she's just going to go
down with the ship of equity and faux
diversity but how about diversity of
thought wouldn't that be nice if you had
a democrat in there who wasn't a
complete brainwash leftist wouldn't that
be something but here we have I couldn't
even tell what was going on there one of
the guys was black maybe he was sort of
black and then he had a guy that maybe
was kind of Latino and a woman with gray
hair who I guess was young I don't know
what's going on here